things are heating up for Channing Tatum
and Jessie J and we're not mad about it
Channing was in the audience for Jesse's
concert in London on Tuesday and
couldn't help but get all gushy over her
on social media he wrote quote this
woman just poured her heart out on stage
at the Royal Albert Hall whoever was
there got to witness something special
Wow
and he also shared this story of her
concert and wrote she went off tonight
look she definitely did and when
Channing says it Channing's right and
Jessie is returning the love she went to
Magic Mike sly tour in London and wrote
this Magic Mike London opening night
Congrats Channing what a show ladies and
gentlemen you don't want to miss this
how cute is that all this social support
that is sweet right yeah I think they're
really sweet together but we want to
know what do you guys think do you think
Channing and Jessie J are a good match
initially I was kind of hurt that Jenna
and Channing didn't work out they were
such a lovely couple but Jessie J is a
bombshell she's so talented she seems to
just have a really good heart and anyone
who has a great heart I'm down for me
too but I do also kind of think she
looks a lot like Jenna everyone's saying
that I think they're both beautiful in
their own right I do see the
singularity's but you know I think
they're their own girls yeah and things
are heating up they've only been dating
since October so this is really fresh
but a source told et that they went on a
romantic getaway to Seattle they told us
quote Channing and Jessie's relationship
is very new they truly just hit it off
Channing really likes Jessie I mean
that's good they've both been through a
lot I'm speaking of Channing and Jenna
while I do think that this is cute I
think Channing and Jenna have been a
little less private than I would assume
coming out of a marriage that long but
what do you guys think do you think that
they would be better off remaining a
little bit more private or are you guys
okay with them being public yeah I want
to know I kind of feel like I'm loving
watching all of this unfold but I think
just for the sake of protecting this new
relationship yeah we keep it private do
you want to talk about new love are you
happy I'm very because we love you so we
want you to be happy
yes I'm very happy thank you for asking
okay let's move on to Jenna Dewan who is
also moving on
she went public with her boyfriend Steve
Kazee he is a Tony Award winning actor
and this came just six months after
filing from divorce with Channing okay
so a source told us that dating other
people is a huge step for both of them
they are both trying their best to give
each other the space they both need to
move forward in life they want the
relationship to stay healthy for their
daughter Everly and they both plan to
make her their very first priority look
at this maturity maturity yeah I know
but I think that they're really amazing
co-parents from the outside looking in
as far as the relationships go they both
seem to be happy so that's all that we
can ask for right yeah yeah we want to
know do you guys think like have
Channing and Jenna jumped into this
relationship too soon or you know should
they have stayed off the market we want
to know what you think yeah let us know
in the comments this was marriage you
guys so think of that but how much time
do you think everyone needs to heal
after ending a marriage especially when
kids are involved yeah that's a hefty
question let us know what you think and
are you happy to see them moving on with
someone new what do you think of
Channing and Jessie J's romance and what
do you guys think of Jenna and Steve I
personally really like Channing and
Jessie together a little more but that's
because we know a little more but do we
think these relationships will even last
that's the big question let's keep a
conversation going across social I'm at
Kourtney underscore tezo and I'm at
Halle underscore Steven alright guys
until next time we've got you covered
for your pop culture fix